es que lo vimos en las noticias,
así que encontramos a este señor,
y grabamos este pequeño video.
CR: Cuando hablo de ti, con gente que te conoce bien, me dicen,
"Larry quiere cambiar el mundo,
y cree que la tecnología puede enseñarnos cómo".
Y eso significa acceso a Internet, tiene que ver con los idiomas.
Pero también significa cómo la gente puede tener acceso
y hacer cosas que afectarán a su comunidad,
y este es un ejemplo.
LP: Sí, así es.
Personalmente me he estado concentrando más en el acceso.
Estamos hablando del futuro.
Recientemente hemos lanzado el ‘Proyecto Loon’
que usa globos para conseguirlo.
Suena a locura. (Podemos enseñarles el video)
De hecho, hoy,
dos de cada tres personas en el mundo no tienen buen acceso a Internet.
Pensamos que esto puede realmente ayudar
de forma más o menos efectiva.
CR: Es un globo. LP: Sí, da acceso a Internet.
CR: ¿Y cómo es que este globo te da acceso a Internet?
Porque creo que atravesaste unos momentos interesantes ¿no?
Dónde tuviste que investigar cómo hacer los globos.
Que no tenían que estar atados.
LP: Sí, y este es un buen ejemplo de innovación.
Habíamos estado dándole vueltas a esta idea unos cinco años,
antes de empezar a trabajarla, pero básicamente no es más que:
¿cómo conseguimos puntos de acceso en lo alto, económicamente?
Normalmente hay que usar satélites y lleva mucho tiempo lanzarlos.
Pero acabas de ver lo fácil que es lanzar un globo y hacerlo subir.
Una vez más es el poder de Internet:
hice una búsqueda y descubrí que hace 30 o 40 años,
alguien lanzó un globo que dio varias vueltas a la tierra.
Así que pensé, ¿por qué no hacemos eso?
Y así es como empezó este proyecto.
CR: ¿Pero no estás a merced de los vientos?
LP: Sí, pero resulta que hicimos unas simulaciones climatológicas,
cosa que verdaderamente no se había hecho nunca,
y si controlas la altitud de los globos,
—que se puede hacer inflándolos, y de otras formas—
resulta que puedes más o menos dirigir hacia dónde van,
así que creo que podemos construir
una red mundial de globos que puede cubrir todo el planeta.
CR: Antes de hablar del futuro y del transporte,
temas que hace tiempo que te obsesionan,
y de tu fascinación con los transportes,
los coches y las bicicletas automáticas,
y hablemos un poco sobre los temas
que hablamos antes con Edward Snowden,
que son seguridad y privacidad.
Tienes que haber estado pensando en eso.
LP: Sí, por supuesto.
Vi la foto de ayer, Sergey con Edward Snowden.
Puede ser que algunos la hayan visto.
Personalmente creo que la seguridad y la privacidad son cosas muy importantes.
Pensamos en ellas conjuntamente,
porque creo que no puede haber privacidad sin seguridad.
Así que déjame hablar primero de la seguridad,
ya que me has preguntado acerca de Snowden y eso,
y luego hablaré un poco sobre privacidad.
Personalmente pienso que es tremendamente decepcionante
que el gobierno haya hecho todo esto y no nos haya dicho nada.
No creo que podamos tener democracia
si tenemos que estar protegiendo a la gente, a nuestros usuarios,
del gobierno,
sobre aspectos de los que nunca hemos hablado.
Y no me refiero a que tengamos que saber
de que ataque terrorista en concreto les preocupa protegernos,
pero lo que sí debemos saber son los parámetros de ello.
Qué tipo de escuchas va a hacer el gobierno, y cómo y por qué.
Esto considero que no lo hemos hablado.
Así que creo que el gobierno,
ha hecho un tremendo deservicio, al hacer todo esto en secreto.
CR: ¿Sin consultar nunca nada con Google?
LP: No con Google, no, con los votantes.
Creo que necesitamos un debate sobre el tema,
o la democracia no funcionará. Sencillamente no es posible.
Así que me da pena que tenga que ser Google
quien proteja a la gente, a nuestros usuarios,
de lo que el gobierno hace en secreto, sin consultar con nadie.
No tiene sentido.
CR: Y luego está el ángulo de la privacidad.
LP: Sí, el ángulo de la privacidad.
Creo que el mundo está cambiando.
Llevamos teléfonos que saben dónde estamos.
Hay muchos más datos personales.
Y, por eso es importante.
Es lógico que la gente se lo plantee seriamente.
Nosotros pasamos mucho tiempo hablándolo, hablando sobre estos temas.
Estoy un poco,
creo que lo más importante que tenemos que hacer es ofrecer opciones.
Ser transparentes sobre qué datos se están recopilando.
Historial de búsquedas, datos de posición.
Estamos encantados con el ‘modo incógnito’ en Chrome,
y queremos aplicarlo a más ámbitos. Es decir, ofrecer más opciones,
una mayor conciencia sobre lo que está sucediendo.
Creo que es muy fácil.
Me preocupa que tiramos
el bebé con el agua del baño.
En tu programa recientemente,
he perdido algo la voz, y no la he recuperado.
Espero recuperarla hablando contigo.
CR: Haré lo que pueda.
LP: Muy bien. Saca tu muñeco vudú y haz lo que tengas que hacer.
Pero cuando pienso que lo publiqué, que saqué toda esa información,
pedimos un estudio de informes médicos sobre casos similares,
y pensando en los informes médicos digo,
¿no sería increíble que todos los informes médicos
estuvieran disponibles, de forma anónima, para medicina de investigación?
Y si alguien accediera a tus datos médicos,
(un médico haciendo investigación)
pudieras ver qué médico accedió a tus datos, y por qué,
y a lo mejor hasta podrías aprender algo sobre tu caso.
Creo que solo haciendo esto salvaríamos 100 000 vidas este año.
CR: Absolutamente. (Aplausos)
LP: Lo que me preocupa, con respecto a la privacidad en Internet,
es que hagamos lo mismo que con los datos médicos:
es que estamos lanzando al bebé junto con el agua del baño,
que no estamos pensando en los grandes beneficios
que pueden surgir de compartir información
con la persona oportuna y en la forma adecuada.
CP: Y la condición necesaria es que haya seguridad
contra abusos de los datos personales.
LP: Sí me pasó lo mismo con el tema de mi voz,
tenía miedo de compartirlo. Sergey me animó y fue algo grande.
CR: Y la reacción ha sido apabullante.
LP: Sí, la gente es súper positiva.
Supimos de miles y miles de personas con problemas similares,
sobre los que hoy no hay datos.
Así que fue algo grande.
CR: Bueno, pues hablemos del futuro,
¿qué pasa contigo y los sistemas de transporte?
LP: Sí. Se ve que es que estaba frustrado
con esto cuanto estaba en el instituto en Michigan.
Tenía que tomar el autobús, usarlo, esperarlo.
Hacía frío, nevaba.
Hice algo de investigación sobre los costos
y me obsesioné con los sistemas de transporte.
CR: Y de ahí salió la idea de un coche automático.
LP: Sí, hace unos 18 años descubrí que estaban trabajando
en coches automáticos, y me fascinó.
Estos proyectos tardan tiempo en arrancar,
pero estoy súper emocionado con las posibilidades de mejorar el mundo.
Cada año hay más de 20 millones de heridos.
En EE. UU. es la primer causa de mortalidad entre los menores de 34 años.
CR: Estás hablando de salvar vidas.
LP: Sí, y también de salvar espacio y de hacernos la vida mejor:
la mitad de Los Angeles son carreteras y aparcamientos
¡la mitad de la superficie!,
y la mayoría de las ciudades se aproximan a esta cifra.
Usar nuestro espacio así es una locura.
CR: ¿Y cuándo llegaremos?
LP: Creo que muy, muy pronto.
Ya hemos conducido más de 160 000 km
de forma totalmente automática.
Estoy súper ilusionado con sacar esto rápido.
CR: Pero no solo hablas de coches automáticos, la idea también es para bicicletas.
LP: Bueno, en Google la idea es dar bicicletas gratis a todos,
y ha resultado increíble en la mayoría de los trayectos.
Se ven bicicletas por todas partes, se están usando 24 horas al día.
CR: Pero también las quieres poner sobre las calles.
LP: Me cuestioné cómo fomentar aún más el uso de las bicicletas.
CR: Creo que tenemos un video.
LP: Si, veamos el video.
Esto es lo que me fascinó.
(Música)
Así es como se podrían separar
las bicicletas de los coches con un costo mínimo.
En fin, parece una locura, pero es que estaba pensando en nuestro campus,
funcionando con las ciudades y eso.
Queriendo fomentar un mayor uso de las bicicletas,
y planteándome como separar las bicicletas del tráfico, de forma efectiva.
Así que busqué, y esto es lo que encontré.
No estamos trabajando en esto, pero te estimula la imaginación.
CR: Déjame cerrar con esto: danos una idea de tu filosofía mental.
Tienes esta idea del equipo x.
No buscas conseguir solamente
un pequeño paso de progreso.
LP: Sí, creo que muchas de las cosas que hemos estado hablado son así,
son, bueno,
casi usaría el concepto económico de adicionalidad,
que significa que estás haciendo algo que no sucedería si tú no lo hicieses.
Creo que cuantas más cosas así puedas hacer, mayor impacto tendrás.
Se trata de hacer cosas que parecen imposibles.
Cuanto más he aprendido de tecnología,
más me he asombrado,
y más me he dado cuenta de lo que no sé.
Y es que con el horizonte tecnológico,
con tu próximo objetivo,
cuanto más aprendes de tecnología,
más aprendes lo que es posible.
Aprendes que los globos son posibles
porque hay un material que los hace posibles.
CR: Algo que encuentro interesante
es que hay muchas personas pensando en el futuro.
Que vienen y van,
pero nunca vemos su implementación.
Estoy pensando en alguien que tú conoces, sobre el que has leído: Tesla.
En este sentido, ¿cuál es tu método?
LP: Yo creo que la invención en sí misma no es suficiente,
Tesla inventó la energía eléctrica que usamos, pero no fue capaz de desplegarla,
eso lo tuvieron que hacer otros, llevó mucho tiempo.
Creo que si podemos combinar ambas cosas,
si concentramos la innovación, la invención,
con la capacidad real de una compañía
para desplegarla y comercializarla,
de alguna manera esto es positivo para el mundo,
es algo esperanzador.
Estoy impresionado en cómo el Proyecto Loon, entusiasmó al público,
porque dio esperanza a los dos tercios del mundo que no tiene Internet.
CR: Este es otro tema acerca de las compañías.
Tú eres una de esas personas que cree
que las corporaciones, bien gestionadas, son un agente de cambio,
LP: Sí. Estoy verdaderamente consternado
con que mucha gente piense que las corporaciones son el diablo personificado.
Tienen muy mala fama.
Creo que algo de razón tienen, quiero decir,
hay corporaciones que están generando
el mismo incremento que hace 50 años, o hace 20.
Pero eso no es lo que necesitamos.
Necesitamos, sobre todo en tecnología,
necesitamos cambios revolucionarios, no incrementales.
CR: Una vez dijiste, creo que cito correctamente,
que te plantearías, en vez de legar tu dinero,
—si lo fueras a dar a una causa—
que simplemente se lo darías a Elon Musk,
porque crees que él puede cambiar el futuro.
LP: Sí, si quieres ir a Marte para respaldar a la humanidad.
Es un objetivo digno, y es una compañía, y es filantrópica.
Así que creo que buscamos hacer cosas similares.
En Google tenemos muchos empleados que se han hecho bastante ricos.
Se gana mucho dinero en tecnología.
Muchos en esta sala son bastante ricos.
Trabajan porque quieren cambiar el mundo.
Quieren mejorarlo.
¿Por qué no es la compañía para la que trabajas
merecedora no solo de tu tiempo,
sino también de tu dinero?
Lo que quiero decir es que no tenemos este concepto.
No concebimos las compañías así.
Creo que es triste, porque las compañías
representan la mayor parte de nuestro esfuerzo,
es donde invertimos la mayor parte de nuestro tiempo,
donde está la mayoría del dinero.
Así que me gustaría poder ayudar más.
CR: Cuando cierro entrevistas suelo hacer esta pregunta:
¿Qué estado mental, que cualidad mental, es la que mejor te ha servido?
Para Rupert Murdoch, entre otros en el mundo de la comunicación es la curiosidad.
Para Bill Gates y Warren Buffet es la concentración.
Así que ya para acabar:
¿Qué cualidad mental te ha permitido pensar en el futuro,
y al mismo tiempo cambiar el presente?
LP: Creo que lo más importante,
pensando en muchas compañías y en porqué no tienen éxito,
porqué en remplazo de compañías hemos tenido una tasa alta,
pues pensando, ¿qué es lo que han hecho mal?,
¿qué han hecho mal todas estas compañías?
Generalmente es porque no vieron venir el futuro.
Así que yo intento encarar esto y pienso,
¿cómo será el futuro?, ¿cómo lo crearemos?,
¿cómo conseguiremos que nuestra organización
se concentre seriamente en esto?,
¿cómo la impulsamos a buen ritmo?
Así que ha sido la curiosidad,
ha sido plantearse cosas que otros no se plantean,
ha sido trabajar en cosas en las que nadie más trabaja,
porque ahí es donde realmente radica la adicionalidad,
y estar dispuesto a hacer eso, a asumir ese riesgo.
Mira Android, me sentía culpable trabajando en Android, cuando empezaba.
Era una pequeña ‘start up’ que compramos.
En realidad no era en lo que estábamos trabajando,
y me sentía culpable invirtiendo tiempo en eso.
Una estupidez, era el futuro, ¿no?
Fue una gran cosa en la que trabajar.
CR: Encantando de verte aquí, encantado de hablar contigo,
ha sido un placer sentarme contigo en esta mesa.
Gracias Larry.
LP: Gracias a ti.
(Aplausos)
Larry Page.